I want to make a quick note in this
video because I realized that some of
these ratio and rate problems these
ratio and rate algebraic problems can
get a little bit confusing so I just
want to make sure you get the intuition
behind it so if I were to tell you that
Sal Sal takes I don't know let's say he
takes one hour to eat a pie let me pick
a number better than one let's say he
takes two hours two hours to eat a pie
so he takes two hours two hours per pie
and let's say Dean let's say Dean takes
three hours to eat a pie so he takes
three hours hours per pie and if I were
to ask you how long does it take for
both of them if they're both working
together how long will it take them to
eat a pie you might be wondering well
what can I just add the two hours per
pie and the three hours for pie why
can't I just do two hours / pi plus
three hours / x + 3 hours per pie why
would this why would this be incorrect
why wouldn't this be their combined rate
and just I guess the best way to think
about is think about what's happening
here you're saying that Sal takes two
hours of pie Dean takes three hours of
pie if they're both working on the same
pie it's going to take them less time
they're going to do it faster but when
you add the hours what are you doing
you're going to get five hours per pie
this is not answering the question how
many hours that will it take for them to
finish one pie this is answering the
question this is answering the question
how much total time would be spent if
they each independently a 2 pi salads
been to and then Dean would spend 3
their total time would be five so we're
just adding x here if you really want to
combine their effort you want to combine
their rates you have to express both of
these in terms of rates and if you want
to express two hours per pie in terms of
rate you would say that this is the same
thing as you just write the ratio the
other way around instead of two hours
per pie you would say one pie for two
hours
two hours or you can view it as one-half
Piper hours now it is expressed as a
rate do the same thing for Dean instead
of three hours per pie you could say
that he would do one pie every three
hours every three hours or another way
to think about it is he does one third
of a pie per hour one third of a pie per
hour now we're speaking in a language of
rates if how how many pies per hour I
can do how many Dean can do if we
combine it then we have our combined
rate so if we add if we had one half
plus one-third plus one-third that is
our combined rate in pies per hour and
what is this equal to one half is 36
plus one-third is 26 which is equal to
56 and all the units here are in pies
pies per hour and then if we wanted to
say how many hours so we would we would
do literally 56 of a pie per hour when
we're eating together now if you want to
say how many hours per pie you would
just write this ratio you would just
flip it so this is the same thing as 6
over 5 hours per pie so hopefully that
makes sense I don't want this to seem
like some type of Voodoo where I just
decide arbitrarily to flip both of these
numbers I'm flipping them so I can
express them as rates which hopefully
make intuitive sense because you can
only add rate you can if you add the
time you're not saying that they're
working on the same pie you're saying
how much total time is it taking them
only when you're flipping them and
combining you're saying hey their rates
are being combined on the same effort I
can combine them and that'll tell you
their combined rate and then you can
take the flip of that and say on a
combined basis how many hours and it
should make it intuitive sense if we're
both eating the same pie it's going to
take let fewer hours than either of us
and six fifths is one in one-fifth hours
or 1.2 hours or one hours and 12 minutes
which makes sense it's a little bit more
than if you had to sals to sals would
take one hour and two Dean's would take
an hour and a half so it's someplace in
between those two numbers which
hopefully makes sense